[Music]  the entire time and with finals he only  ever had one call to worry about half  the universe we are out of time  [Music]  the end is near  [Music]  get tickets now  the entire time I knew him he only ever  had one goal  to wipe out half the universe if he gets  all the Infinity stones she can do it  with the snap of his fingers just like  that tell me his name again  Tanis  [Music]  we got one advantage  she's coming to us  we have a dance once so that's what we  use  [Music]  let's talk about this plan ears I think  it's good except it sucks so let me do  the plan and that way it might be really  good Wow  is near  and um  [Music]  half of humanity will still exist  perfectly balanced  as all things should be  I hope they remember you  [Music]  I'm Peter by the way dr. strange oh  you're using your made-up names then I  am spider-man  [Music]